if you had to ask for a hall pass for
any like celebrity crush or anything who
would you ask for John Stamo this is
getting juicy you try to get them unlaid
Anthony what are you doing
get new subscribers somebody's working
hard here on the damn show Let's Do It
Whatever the Chamberlain person is
[Laughter]
one of the greatest scorers of all time
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing and uh
interesting episode of careful boys we
have with us Mr Brecken right here hello
for those of you don't know Brecken is
Kristen's boyfriend he was just hanging
out today we decided to put him in this
chair because we're gonna ask him a
bunch of questions about Kristen
anything
you gotta let him finish what he's
saying if he's talking about you he
never finishes sandwiches oh
sorry this is his okay
she's talking about come I know that's
what I was thinking about it just feels
wrong you guys can ask Rick and whatever
you want how'd y'all meet
we met uh through a mutual friend his
name's Tyler really dope guy looks like
Miles Morales is this Maverick he looks
like Miles Morales okay was it uh was it
Love at First Sight 100 really oh well
actually we did you see her go God damn
it she fine how'd you react to see it
well I was like kind of talking in the
end of a relationship with someone who
you know they became really good friends
like it ended up ending really hopefully
but
um the first time like she just made me
feel like a little kid is I didn't even
know her and she just kept giving me
these sand crabs that she was Finding on
the beach
what were they you mean the little ones
yeah he didn't know that the sand crabs
are there fake game crabs nice all right
so you get crabs got it last question
she gave him grabs on the first day
all right hey but can I can I jump in
just a minute damn what up no but
basically he was kind of like in a
relationship with someone and they're in
a music duo it's called Brecken Mari
they're amazing I met them as friends
that day was kind of like off and weird
you know I felt something weird with
Mari I I'm gonna be honest like I wasn't
looking at him like that because I
thought he was with this girl so I
didn't have like that or anything no I
was playing with crabs no intentional
hard wrecking yet and I was like I was
like look there's crabs and he's like
wow
what ended up happening is like I
started meeting this group of friends
they were awesome but I still thought
they were dating
um sometime it goes by a couple months I
fell off the roof we talked about that
before I came to La it was New Year's I
was in a cast I was all drugged up he's
like hey I'm having people at my house
for a New Year's party come over I was
like cool I heard that they weren't
dating anymore and the girl was talking
to someone else he decided decides to
kiss me while he was in a castle of
drugs
[Applause]
I sit next to the girls they're all in a
puddle and I loved Mari like I love Mari
so much and she's sitting down so I
snuggle right next to her I didn't know
she saw the kiss and I don't know if she
was pissed about it so you're holding
her damn being like because I'm like
such a loving person I'm like you know
cuddling her on the couch and she looks
at me and she's like I saw what happened
I know what you did and my heart just
dropped so I was like it's done if you
want this to be done like I don't do
that and she's like no it's actually a
good thing so she ended up dating the
other guy me and Brecken started writing
and now you know we're pretty much
friends but it was a funny situation
okay I'm gonna shut up wow that is the
widest thing I've ever heard
like exchanging a girlfriend like you
know what yeah it's so sensible but it
was just so it's so mature yeah
I thought it was gonna be like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I know you guys were
talking about like fights and stuff me
and my friends are like tell me how you
feel
you're like good for y'all so man to man
yes what's the thing about Christian
that turns you on the most
if there's nothing we can go to the next
question by the way
definitely when she wears like this
little workout outfit but it's like a
nude workout oh it's a specific one
like a skims like a cut like a yeah yeah
peach colored
icy
okay she didn't know that
I'm wearing new today more now I know
what I'm changing into today
what's like Chris's most unattractive
quality what the [ __ ] you're gonna try
to get her to put clothes on now you're
honest
none probably she bites her nails a lot
when she's nervous oh I hate you can't
tell because but she gets it from her
dad oh yeah how long have y'all been
together
17 months
what's that tubeout
like two weeks oh okay two years 17
months like a baby I'm 14. like a baby
yeah that was okay yeah that was pretty
interesting 17 months is it really
though is that like actually the
what was the hardest point in your
guys's relationship I don't know we kind
of both went through a really depressing
time we weren't like for the first year
I kind of blew up music like I didn't
work on music she didn't dance like all
we wanted to do was just lay in bed with
each other
and stuff but it was like a honeymoon
phase for like a whole entire year and
it hasn't gone away but we kind of
figured out our lives got a routine and
now we're a lot what was y'all's first
uh argument yeah the first bad one
have we had like a bad bad argument oh
my God I'm so cute
so so we're not the we're not the are
you type like you said this before the
camera was rolling I'm not
a very she's hard to piss off and he's
super chill and I was like I can't
imagine I mean
first argument I don't know really what
are your fights like yeah how do you
fight what are your fights like online
I like space I don't really fight I'm
like one that I'm like are you a flight
give me a second no I'm like I'm not a
flight I'm like I just need a second
that's good all right if you uh if you
if you had to uh ask for a hall pass for
any like celebrity crush or anything who
would you ask for
John Stamos John Stevens
um this is getting juicy you're trying
to get them unlaid Anthony what you do
what are you doing I'm trying to [ __ ]
get new subscribers somebody's working
hard here on the damn show let's do it
he said unlaid I would say hmm you do
like
joints whatever the Chamberlain person
is
[Laughter]
a YouTuber
oh I know who that is yeah who's this
yeah she's massive
yeah she like hosted let me see she got
big titties no so I feel like so this is
something you need to know about Brecken
is like wait not perfect
I wanted to pick up those board photos
not like attraction like she's a really
dope girl like reckon likes
personalities you know oh you're a Vibe
guy Vibes you're a bad guy
he's not a tits and ask her what about
your Holocaust request yeah who would
you be Boykins
um can Jarvis watch Ryan Reynolds I like
his personality too I don't know
your personality her personality people
and that's why yeah but you both look
good though what are you talking about
your personality people you chose
Attractive people we don't believe you
if both of you are ugly as [ __ ] I
[ __ ] I I'd understand he met me when
I like it was like completely crippled
Kim breaking dance yeah no he can't
dance is that a is that a thing where
you try to like get him to dance
um well he's surrounded by my friends I
have a lot of friends that dance so
he'll like bust out somewhere sometimes
I used to jerk fat in high school not
she's not hurt no [ __ ] that was yeah
no but did you used to do a little bit
of um did you do a little breaking like
you know you know how to clap Rock coin
drop oh okay yeah from the base like
let's go there's a lot of you get hyphy
with it yeah that's that's very hyping
yeah hell yeah what's what's the next
step in you guys relationship this is
getting warm as [ __ ] it was a [ __ ]
Hallmark commercial they're two goddamn
[ __ ] sweet dog I know they're too
sweet I want something spicy give me
some corruption so no some spicy about
me come on just this is this is a this
is a gen Z success story right here
beautiful
they're like what's wrong in your
relationship they're like nothing yeah
we're doing it right that's for sure
get juicy come on Ryan you know me the
best did she ever lie to you about
someone
I mean
a lot but like in release
[Laughter]
let's say we're like playing rocket
League which we've never done video game
okay this is so PG and she says you know
I'm like did you just bump me she's like
no no of course not and then I got back
to the replay and it's like
okay you guys are too cute I love it
yeah we're at the nine minute 56 second
point of the video where things turn
turn up the heat a little bit uh we
always ask our guests this you know what
I mean uh but before anybody answers
we're just obviously this unique
scenario with two of you guys here
usually we ask our Aussie guests would
you uh would you rather [ __ ] your mom or
dad um but maybe maybe swap parents
Kristen has to answer what you think he
would rather do [ __ ] his mom or his dad
oh probably his dad his dad is a boss
wait that's why
no not not who you want to [ __ ] who he
is
all right so was she did she answer
right or wrong you're dead yeah he's
quick straight to the point there's no
over fast
I I got a question I got a question if
your parents told you you can't be with
Christian what would you do would you be
a good boy and say would you yes okay
Mom and Dad I'll do it what would you be
like no I [ __ ] love her and we're
gonna run away together You Don't Know
Her Like I Do yeah oh you would do that
what if they're like hey but if you if
you break up with her right now uh you
have all the property and we'll give you
a hundred thousand cash well that's a
good you should pick that one and you
change your name I would say that that's
smart so you do a ski you should you
should pick that I'll take your parents
house any day where's the wildest Place
y'all had sex
wildest gosh
oh yeah
wait what is this new year the night
that we met this is New Year's
a bunch of people are sleeping over at
my house it wasn't a bed but it was kind
of funny I don't know it's funny for you
guys but my homie was sleeping it's a
queen bed so it's not a twin but he was
on the very left Edge in some way
somehow I inserted myself she was
conscious
our homie was sleeping next to us
because it was weird because so you're
just making it [ __ ] water bad move on
him huh like the nights you met no no
New Year's New Years New Years oh
hitting her up on the DMs like she had a
picture of her fireplace I'm like oh
where's this she was like come over
never did so it was your friend like
hahaha
it was just a quick note how you doing
and then quickly how you doing
but we also wanted like someone sleeping
in there because we didn't want Mari
thinking like anything weird it was even
though it was happening really awkward
time and that same night our other
friend who's actually our boy now who
actually lives with us he confessed to
me he got he's the one who introduced us
he got pissed that me and Brecken
started dating because apparently he
told me he was in love with me and I was
like oh and he lives with y'all now
[ __ ] drugs and stuff and I'm like
what is happening like this whole house
everybody trying to [ __ ] children
everyone thinks they're a sex quote fit
no everyone thinks you're a sex cool
yeah we've gotten that they have a they
have a collective called unicorn
Collective it's a bunch of artists A lot
of people are in music and producers and
stuff but everyone's very friendly and
like family and we're a really close
Group which is admirable from the
outside people have asked us if we're a
sex cult
and
you guys already like did the time might
as well do the crime though right
if that's correct yeah that's so funny
damn hey so okay what about the parents
like the first time you met her parents
was it like automatic approval what is
it like yeah cause your dad's a cop yeah
did he go no no it's kind of funny
because
I wasn't much of a talker when I met him
I was kind of nervous and he was the
same way so when we were just both in
the car and I like asked Chris and I'm
like why isn't your dad talked to me and
apparently he did that same exact thing
asking me why yeah we were when they
first met so yeah Brecken was like a
little bit more reserved and then my
dad's also kind of a guy that's to
himself and I had both of them pulling
me aside like hey why isn't he talking
to me and then my dad's like why isn't
he talking to me and I was like you guys
just [ __ ] talk together and then they
talked to this chill now did your dad
ever look up his records probably wow I
mean records like music or records like
priors oh yo he's got fired
was it cool was it like uh is I mean or
he's a cop though retired lieutenant
yeah was it over a beer you guys crack
one
called cobra
no didn't he have a he had like a
margarita I think he doesn't drink a lot
but a little like he gets he gets my dad
was definitely my dad I mean I'm the
baby so he's very skeptical he's like
who is this guy but if if uh Kristen
cheated on you would you forgive her if
she was really sorry that came quick
dude I tried to make an iron
so you get you get one uh Chris is like
oh I do have a hall pass ready then okay
ready so wow that's really gonna get one
that's amazing who farts louder
sweep
this one but probably me when I'm like
trying to he's lying in her sleep he
says I fart in my sleep there's no way
how is there no way well there's a way
but not like is excessive and Loud how
would you know you're sleeping okay well
why is it here like curled over I just
do you ever wake does she wake herself
up sometimes
no but she like what that [ __ ] say
her sleep talking is so funny oh what is
she saying herself oh I'm a sleep talker
it's like the most random things I have
a voice recording of her like saying
something about
pushing the smash button to the toe
blender or like what was it on a
smoothie I woke up you
soda cup there's like the button yeah in
my sleep I was talking about the little
smash buttons
um how interesting
let's say let's say uh let's say I don't
know if she's like pregnant one day
right and then like nine months later
it's like it was such a warm experience
baby comes out dark as hell
looks like me
[Laughter]
[Music]
he dated a porn star before me wow what
was his name uh Sam e Sam e Sam e how
was that it was interesting we like
matched on Tinder I didn't know she was
a previous porn star but she was six
three so it was kind of weird well
you're tall too yeah I'm six four but
yeah I've never been with someone like
that tall so I kind of felt like I was
like [ __ ] myself
[Laughter]
oh yeah odds are most girls are gonna be
smaller than you by a lot yeah when we
speak there was no like small spin y'all
are both big spoons yeah yeah and just a
couple of punch bowl ladles yeah Rebecca
what was your first impression of us
of you guys you know them yeah how uh
when she said just kidding news I was
like just kidding
that's just getting filmed so my homie
Nick fanisi in high school showed me
this video that's still my favorite uh
special ingredient oh
China Memphis
oh yeah Ah that's racist
it's okay he gets a pass he was quoting
us that was really good hey you did it
pretty good yeah it was good actually I
felt like where'd you grow up yeah on
that Creek so Walnut Creek oh so you had
you had friends the Gateway you into the
JK world because I might be blowing
friends that's tight man what a small
world
did you make the connection that was us
when she started coming on to JK news
yeah because I you looked really
familiar than the BART panda hat yeah
that's smart yeah panda panda hat oh wow
that is Throwback that is super old
school I'm a fan too
[Laughter]
I got it what would um this is a
question for you have you ever heard
like when he makes music and he's like
yo check it out
not liked it but you didn't want to say
something
yeah I've been I've been I've been
honest I mean I actually really like his
music I wouldn't date him if he wasn't
talented and is going to support me in
life but
um yeah I mean sometimes there's been
stuff but I'm here's the thing I know
like the finished product is gonna end
up good so like baby I'm gonna be honest
like some of those songs where you
wanted because usually the girl sings
and he produces you know when you
started singing on some of those tracks
I was like
okay
but okay in a good way no take some
lessons Okay no but but the way it
no but you've gotten better at saying
yeah the mixing and mastering is really
good you've improved a lot [ __ ] you guys
bye-bye I know I have to listen to it
back and try to fix it there's Auto
tuning there's uh you know a tune
correction there's pitch correction
there's a way to just keep [ __ ]
nailing it in huh
you can sound like [ __ ] James Franco
like [ __ ] that you wake up a [ __ ]
amazing singer you got practice dude oh
hi Mark we all got to practice
Yeah okay has there ever been a dance
video you saw of her and you were like
I don't think so wow yeah I appreciate
like all the Styles and Kristen you're
fine
ouch who uh who who who who cooks mainly
[Laughter]
yeah he makes great steak but we don't
cook that much he got me bad into
Postmates
but he does love food so we go out to
eat all the time he always has
restaurants to try adds up
one thing that pisses me off the most
about him I like this volunteering bring
it up all right so and but it's food
related so I grew up very uncultured
with food I'm a picky eater but as I'm
getting older I'm trying more things
right I didn't try sushi just ate cheese
sandwiches Wisconsin yeah but he makes
me try food all the time he knows I
don't like mayonnaise mayonnaise and
he'll be like here put mayonnaise on
that and I'm like no and he's like try
my sandwich there's mayonnaise on it and
I'm like no but he'll expand your
palette literally just like shove it
down my throat
and then feed you a sandwich
something about like condiments can't do
like like I can't imagine just eating I
mean I can I've done it before like a
meat cheese sandwich without any sauce
or anything no tomato no
I mean you're a peppercini fan so I
could get peppercini
yes did you guys have a pet together
Cairo Pomeranian Shih Tzu mix is that
y'all got it together no it tastes but
it's mine
gotcha yeah it's one of those so he he
had a dog a little dog and then I found
a cat on the street
um
and I brought it in and it's actually
like a five thousand dollar cat what the
heck it's a savannah bangle mix you
found a savannah bagel on the street yes
and I may have oh he's been trying to
find one and he knows I lost one
recently
on the streets
and I was like
is that a baby bobcat tiger and
and then I was like don't let the cat
out of the bag and I was like oh that's
where it comes from and then I raised it
took it to the vet none of the neighbors
knew whose cat it was so I kept it
so we have two kids oh nice and I've
always wanted a Savannah cat my whole
life's over oh those are [ __ ]
expensive okay you have to answer this
last question at the same time okay
don't look at each other's eyes okay who
dominates in the bedroom three two one
Kristen whoa in the relationship in the
relationship look who's wearing the
leather jacket yo yeah throw that last
one out yeah but but it works somehow I
mean he definitely has his it's not like
I'm just like alpha female and just have
them on a leash but
um yeah I'm a very
excuses
a little monkey backpack whoa okay
good answer
foreign
[Music]
[Music]